[موسيقى]
هذا هو غضب الطبيعة الذي تم التقاطه بواسطة
التصوير الفوتوغرافي بطائرات بدون طيار ، وآمل ألا أفقد
هذه الطائرة لأن اللقطات مجنونة
[موسيقى]
لديك الكثير من الأدرينالين ، مثل
الطيور ويمكنك الطيران أينما
تريد  ليس فقط أي طائرة بدون طيار ،
هذا هو العالم السينمائي
لمنظر الشخص الأول
fpv
[موسيقى]
بقدر ما تذهب لقطات الطائرات بدون طيار ، فأنت على الأرجح على
دراية بهذه
حيث يتم توجيه الطائرات بدون طيار من الأرض
مع طيارين fpv يطيرون من وجهة نظر الطائرات بدون طيار
ويشاهدون البث المباشر
من زوج من النظارات الواقية التي
تسمح للقطات أن تكون أكثر ديناميكية
وسرعة ، لديك المزيد من المحاور التي
تطفو بالفعل عندما تطير fpv ،
تلاحظ أنك تستكشف الطبيعة من
منظور لا يمكنك حتى
أن تقابل المروحية أليس من
سويسرا ، لذلك أنا  أعني أنني أحبها فقط
وخوليو من كوستاريكا من
جوانب مختلفة من العالم ، كلاهما يتشاركان
شغفًا لالتقاط مقاطع فيديو fpv سينمائية ،
أود أن أقول إن fpv يسمح لك
في الواقع بالحفاظ على تدفق تلك القصة.
صور خوليو ngs spicy في عام 2021 انفجار
بركان باكايا في غواتيمالا بعد
أنهار الحمم المتدفقة بطائرته بدون طيار
من أجل التقاط هذه الطلقات ،
صعد الجبل في منتصف
الليل وانتظر أول ضوء في الساعة 5
صباحًا.  لتدفق
الحمم البركانية على بعد 50 مترًا ، كنت أطير
بأقصى سرعة مع هذه الطائرة بدون طيار
للتأكد من أنها لن تذوب من
أجل إليس ، فقد استغرق الأمر سنوات للوصول إلى
شلالات الملاك في فنزويلا ،
أطول شلال في العالم منذ ظهور fpv
أخبرت نفسي أنني يجب أن أذهب إلى هناك
[موسيقى]
لتصوير هذه التسلسلات ، وقف إليس على
متن قارب له خط رؤية مباشر
لمسار رحلته ، وكان عليهم إبقاء القارب
في منتصف النهر بالضبط إذا
ذهبوا كثيرًا إلى  المصعد يحتوي على فروع
من الأشجار التي تغلق إشارتي تجعل الأمر
صعبًا حقًا إذا خرجت
مسافة أربعة كيلومترات ، لذا عليك أن تظل
في نفس المكان تمامًا
بينما قد يكون من السهل أن تضيع في
اللقطات الرائعة
خلف الكواليس ، فإن تصوير fpv أصعب
من  يبدو أن
هناك الكثير من التخطيط للرحلة ،
على سبيل المثال ، لديها عدد لا بأس به من
ست طائرات بدون طيار ، حسنًا ، خمس طائرات بدون طيار
على الأقل
، تستغرق الرحلة الفعلية الصبر
والأعصاب حيث يجب على جميع الطيارين مواجهة
مخاوفهم الأكبر ، لن أقول مثل
فترات مثل  لقد فقدت الأدرينالين ، نعم ، لقد
كنت مغرورًا للغاية ،
لقد ذهبت للغوص النهائي ،
لقد فقدت للتو طائرتك بدون طيار التي فقدتها
وبالطبع فقدت اللقطات
أيضًا وفقدت ألف دولار كل ما كنت
أفكر فيه هو أوه ، أرجوك عودي إلى المنزل ،
أرجوك تعال  في المنزل وفي كل
مرة يفعل ذلك ، كنت سعيدًا جدًا ، نعم
كل رحلة هي احتفال
لكل من جوليو وإيليس ، يوفر عملهم fpv
فرصًا
للإبداع واستعراض مهاراتهم التقنية ، لقد قضيت على
الأرجح ألف وأربعمائة ساعة
في التقنية فقط  الطائرات بدون طيار fpv ،
فأنت تفهم المكونات الفنية
وتفهم القيد الذي
تعرفه إلى أي مدى يمكنك أن تذهب أثناء
الإبداع هو حدودك كما لو
كانت
[موسيقى]
من  قمم جبال الدولوميت
، وبراكين كوستاريكا ،
وسواحل جزر الفرعون ،
وأطلال المايا القديمة في غواتيمالا ،
والمعرفة الفنية والإبداع ،
والأدرينالين يجتمعان معًا لخلق
تجربة بصرية نهائية
لك